organized people aren't don't have a way
of learning about citizenship if you
take the core of this ideal to be the
citizen we the people and you think in
legal terms of how do we legally express
our citizenship we have very little
means in a way we vote it's true but our
vote our vote is just one drop in an
ocean we don't really feel a sense of
control through our individual votes but
jury now jury is something different
it's not something that we're doing all
the time but when we are called upon to
serve on a jury then we are doing
something serious and actually the only
job that the Constitution defines for a
citizen all the rest that is talked
about citizenship is what the state says
should be expected of you as a citizen
you are to serve the state but no no you
turn around from the point of view of We
the People trying to frame a state in
which we maintain some hold the jury
that's our opportunity to participate so
for me the empowered citizen is the
place where the Declaration of
Independence starts it's expressed in
the jury in our Constitution and we have
all we need even now to make it work